so one of the prevailing motifs here on
shots of awe is as human beings as
conscious agents how do we resolve the
inherent tension between wanting to
realize to fully realize our potential
to realize ourselves as individuals we
stand with dignity and resist the tug of
conformity how do we avoid succumbing to
a zombified trance state of blindly
following others in a herd as sheep as
hamsters in a hamster wheels and you
know it's funny because I think that the
way we resolved that is by taking that
plunge by answering that call that
joseph campbell talks about there is no
one math for how to live our lives
reality is just a word and you're not
supposed to use it without quotation
marks around it anyway as Joseph
Campbell says we are all free to create
a reality but it's only when we are bold
enough to decondition our thinking to
transcend what Robert Anton Wilson calls
the reality tunnel right this linguistic
and conceptual and symbolic framework
structured realities and a matrix pulled
in front of your eyes blinding you from
ecstatic visions of what might be behind
those walls you know we are larvas who
haven't turned ourselves into
butterflies yet and there's a great line
by Nietzsche that says those who were
seeing dancing were called insane by
those who could not hear the music
and we forget the words of Jack Kerouac
the only people for me are the mad ones
mad to live mad to talk mad to be saved
desirous of everything at the same time
those who never yawn or say a
commonplace thing that burn burn burn
like yellow roman candles exploding like
spiders across the sky